this we are actually in my fun house on
the set of my late night show which is a
fun house and behind me
is a cloud decal we got a gray couch
with some funky pillows i'm wearing
sunflowers
it's a great day it's a great vibe you
know what's a great vibe
as well is 2021 new beginnings and you
know
you my friend how are you doing
spiritually
thank you for asking i'm doing well i
think i had that realization like many
other people when we hit 2021 at
midnight we were like
ten nine eight seven six seven four
three two one it's exactly like 20 20.
it's literally exactly like 20 20.
um but you know what i i had to reflect
and meditate and i am of the belief that
we should not trash on 2020 anymore
i think 2020 was rough but i also think
there was a lot of beautiful silver
linings and i think people came together
in beautiful ways and so i'm choosing to
focus on that
and i love that because you just put an
instagram post out that really got to me
girl thank you for doing that and
speaking your
truth i mean have you found i guess your
happiness
through all of this yeah i think
happiness you know i've really learned
as cliche as it sounds that it's not a
destination it definitely is a journey
um and i have just
especially through season one and season
two and my work life and my personal
life and all that stuff
i've just learned that every day it's
important to prioritize happiness and
having fun
it's not just a goal for down the road
it's every day is what i'm trying to do
so some days
am i happy yes some days am i less happy
yeah but that's life
a little late for a little lily saying
the fact that we're going to season two
i understand there's a lot of changes
that are happening like you said you
ditched
the desk you're in this beautiful vibe
and you have new writers that are more
gender balanced diverse is this going to
bring more of your authentic
you into season two um
yes and no yes because i do believe that
inclusion and a writer's room and a crew
and a set looking like the world is
important i think it's important to have
all those povs and
honestly it's just the environment i
want to be in i want you know to reflect
the world
but the reason i say no is because it's
not up to my writers and my crew and all
that to bring
my authentic self to late night it's up
to me you know and i think
it's my responsibility to do that it's
my responsibility to show up every day
and say
this is the real me i am throwing away
all my inhibitions i am going to be my
genuine self because that takes courage
and confidence
and you know and i think in season one
and some other projects i have that
confidence sometimes
but not daily and now i can confidently
say that
in season two every day i show up as
myself completely my
love that so how is season two going to
be different from season one
so many ways for one you see my outfit
yes for season two i actually had a suit
picked out for this interview and i just
walked into my hair makeup room and i
said you know what today i'm feeling
more like just casual and more meat and
so i literally just didn't wear the suit
and wore this and that's the vibe for
season two in general
whatever makes me thrive me feel
comfortable me feel like myself is what
is going to happen
you know i don't want to show up like
someone else i'm not going to change my
mannerisms i'm not going to change my
imperfections to try to appeal to people
and be me and i'm going to have fun and
i'm going to hope that the audience
really sees
that i'm having fun um so yeah we're
shooting in a house not a studio
uh i am kind of merging some of my
youtube
attitude into this show in the sense of
like
uh you know not having to hit a mark and
be perfect
not having to redo things if i make a
mistake i'm embracing mistakes
there's no audience obviously because of
the world but the crew
is my audience i'm interacting with the
crew i'm having banter with my sound guy
um you're just seeing more me hmm
i love your energy there's something
different about you i'm just
different you know what it is i'm
prioritizing
having fun i think i
for so long believed that and i still
believe in the hustle and i still
believe in working so hard and
not being entitled and keeping your head
down and doing the work but i think i
didn't prioritize
fun as much before um
and i i saw it i saw it on the screen i
saw myself stressed i saw myself not
having fun i just learned when you have
fun
you truly don't have regrets
i love that and you had mindy kaling as
your first guest in season one
who will be for season two who can we
expect will we see more skits
what can you tell us give us some
teasers for sure in terms of first guest
i'll let you know when i find out girl
okay
we don't know yet but uh in terms of
guests one thing i wanted to change was
in season one i was so grateful for
everyone that came on my show because
it's a 1 30 a.m show it takes a lot of
effort to go into hair and makeup
and sit there i know how it is it takes
a lot of energy and effort so i'm so
grateful but
i am also a believer that yeah we want
to hear from celebrities and actors and
actors and musicians but
i also want to talk to people who are
not necessarily famous
but have dope things to say and are
doing great things you know there's so
many people
that have great initiatives or have
written great books are doing great
things in their communities
that have never had the opportunity to
be on late night and they have great
stories and
they're the type of people that deserve
the platform of late night so i have
i want to have a lot of guests that
aren't traditional celebrities
um there's a lot more sketch one of my
biggest
one of the biggest things i missed in
season one was not having as much sketch
because it's a jigsaw puzzle with
scheduling and you know just trying to
figure it all out
every episode at minimum is gonna have
one sketch in season two that is my gut
and
my promise is going to be every episode
has at least one sketch
i love that and you know i i told people
that i was going to be talking to you
today and
a lot of people talked about the fact
that you spoke about what's happening in
india and talking about the protest
and your pe your parents are from punjab
as well and i mean what can we do going
forward in terms of bringing awareness
how can we help and why is it so
important to you to use your platform to
speak about this situation
that's a really good question and if i'm
being honest i don't
have all the right answers like this is
something i think about daily and i try
to figure out for myself and i think
people assume that because i have the
platform i have i might have all the
answers and i'm just going to genuinely
say i don't
you know like everyone else i'm trying
my best and i think it's about
really reflecting and thinking about
which causes mean a lot to you
because realistically i know i can't
solve
every problem and if i tried to stand
for everything
i would stand for nothing right and so i
really have to reflect on
what are the causes i can speak on
genuinely and that i can actually move
the needle
and so you know because my parents are
from punjab i did feel compelled
and genuinely passionate about speaking
about the farmer protests happening in
india
um and it's a tough thing it's a tough
thing to negotiate because
you know social media is tricky there's
you know cancer culture is a real thing
when you're talking about causes that
are important
the conversation of cancer culture
always goes hand in hand unfortunately
and i think if there's one thing i would
love to
stand for it's to lead with compassion
and education
i do think the way to move forward is to
educate people
is to welcome people into the
conversation is to do so with open arms
and i think it's detrimental and
counterproductive to say
to start dividing more so based on these
causes so i'm always going to be of the
belief that talk about things that are
important to you do your research
and welcome people into that
conversation however best you can and
that's what i've been doing
i love you season two i can't wait i
love the vibe
and congratulations thank you so much
not with the hard tea not singing about
you girl
bye everyone thank you
you